Film Courage: Can you tell us a time in your
life when you were the most broke making films?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker: Most broke?
Man…I remember…true story.
2006 I moved my office to Beverly Hills, I
had an office off of Beverly Drive.
It was in a famous building, ICM was in there.
I was in Spike Lee’s old office.
I remember I was still getting his mail and
for his manager or producing partner or something.
And I had started my business out of my apartment
and sold a couple of films and I’m like
alright, I’m going to take my business and
I’m trying to grow.
So I had agreed to open up this office in
Beverly Hills.
I remember the rent was high as hell.
So I had my rent for the office and I had
my rent for where I was living and I ended
up partnering with another friend of mine
at the back lot of Universal and that was
some money involved there, too.
I remember in 2006 I shot three movies and
it wasn’t easy and I remember after shooting
those three movies it had just exhausted all
of my funds.
I remember one of those movies kind of went
over budget or something like that.
So it was like ah…man!
I got hit with not having money to pay my
rent for the office…or I had to get out
of there.
One of those things, I couldn’t afford to
stay there.
So I wound up moving out of the office to
save some money there and I had these three
films SINGLE BLACK FEMALE, UNEMPLOYED, and
this movie WHAT UP?
And I don’t know how I managed to shoot
those three movies in one year but it tapped
out my funds and I had to sell the movies
to get everything back and going.
But selling three movies is not easy because
they were different movies and I remember
people offering me not the right offers for
my films and I remember that I had to figure
some stuff out.
I ended up luckily at the end of the year
after basically being at the end of my savings
and everything.
I remember my [car] tags were expired.
I couldn’t afford to register my car because
I was just holding onto these movies and I
wouldn’t let them go unless it was like
the right price and I remember staying broke
until the right situation came by.
And I prayed and prayed and prayed.
And there were people who were in the position
to help me with distribution and the were
basically trying to extort me.
They were trying to get my movies for little
to nothing.
They thought I was desperate because some
close friends of mine kind of knew my personal
situation that were in the business.
They were trying to take my movie from me
for little or nothing.
And I refused because I know my value and
I know the value of the current marketplace
and I’m like “I’m going to hold out.”
By the grace of God I was able to sell two
of my movies to Lionsgate.
One of them was UNEMPLOYED and the other one
was through my other partner, called WHAT
UP?
They both went through Lionsgate.
And I brokered one of the deals on my own
so I didn’t have to owe anyone a finder’s
fee or a producer rep fee or anything like
that, you know what I mean?
But I held out and I went from nothing to
something real quick.
But I remember that year going into 2008 was
pretty rough but it started in 2007.
Around 2007 I had to make a fight, a comeback.
And I didn’t make a comeback until I sold
my films to Lionsgate.
But there was a period where all the money
I had was going to rent just to keep my operation
going.
Just to keep the doors open in Beverly Hills.
It was like Oh man…you know my ego and everything
was coming in play…and it was like “Oh
man!”
And I was about to move my office back home
or whatever the case may be but as technology
and everything changed and things became more
expensive people like myself started to have
a home office anyway because of Internet and
everything, it’s easier.
So now I’ll work in an office when I’m
in production, so I’ll rent the office space
when I’m in production for three or four
months for the duration of production and
then take everything else back to home base
because it’s just more economical for me
that way because everything is expensive in
LA.
Like rent alone can run you 2,000 for the
right place, you know what I mean?
You’re trying to have that professional
facade, you’re trying to charge certain
rates and everything so it costs to be the
boss.
Film Courage: That’s interesting because
I think this is a story that a lot of people
in LA had kind of had something nice and then
it took a dip and they’ve come back (at
least the ones who have stayed).
So once you come back what’s your mindset
knowing that (because you said you went from
nothing to something) but I’m sure those
feelings of having to move out of that office
don’t go away.
I mean you still remember that.
Dale: Yes I do and to be honest I wish I’d
never moved into that office because I would
have saved over 30,000 if I’d just kept
to my template of how I was doing things I
would have been in a better financial situation
but I don’t regret it because everything
in life you learn from.
You take the good and the bad and you muster
it up into a lesson.
So I was very glad to say “Hey I had an
office.”
Spike Lee’s old office, I was working with
a big heavyweight producer and right above
Madeo restaurant in Beverly Hills.
It was a good experience and I actually produced
movies out of my office.
Some people have offices and then don’t
to any stuff with it, it’s just a front
of whatever.
But I actually had auditions, I had actors
coming in, I actually made the office very
active and friendly atmosphere.
The other producers that I was sharing an
office space with they weren’t really as
active as me.
Like I have people meeting, coming in, I’m
spending 1,600-1,800 a month on office space.
I want to make sure I’m doing what I’m
supposed to be doing.
And all that energy and meetings and bringing
people to me and trying to manifest productions
and budget it all, I’ve learned from it
and it’s made me who I am today.
I don’t regret it, you know what I mean.
You live and learn and now I’m on a positive
waive right now.
I’ve got a couple of films released into
the marketplace and I’m building off of
that and trying to slide into TV.
It’s just like staying persistent, persistency
is the key… persistency.